im heutigen Video geht es um das
türkreich und mehrdeutige Taktieren von
Mächten einem Spiel mit dem Feuer um
nationale Video strategische Ziele auch
unter in kaufname hoher Risiken zu
erreichen passend dazu haben wir euch
ein Online PvP Game ausgesucht in den
ihr dieses Game strategische Pokerspiel
selbst ausprobieren könnt natürlich ohne
das Schicksal der echten Welt aufs Spiel
zu setzen bevor wir also in die reale
Geopolitik einsteigen möchten wir euch
den Sponsor vorstellen der das heutige
Video möglich gemacht hat Konflikt auf
Nations in Konflikt auf nations world
Stream übernimmst du die Kontrolle über
die Streitkräfte einer der globalen
führende Nationen die für ihre
militärische Expansion wirtschaftliche
Entwicklung technologische Forschung und
internationale diplomative
verantwortlich ist es handelt sich um
ein recht beliebtes Langzeitstudie
gespielt das auf dem PC im Web Browser
oder auf dem Handy gespielt werden kann
und bei dem in einem Match bis zu 100
Spieler miteinander um die globale
Vorherrschaft kämpfen du brauchst nach
und nach deine Infrastruktur und
Streitkräfte auch und beginnst dann
Gegner zu bekämpfen und Direktorium zu
beanspruchen mit den anderen
menschlichen Spieler gegen die du online
antrittst kannst du chatten auf diese
Art eine vielfältige Diplomatie
entfalten das Konzept der
Langzeitstrategie von Konflikt of
Nations erzeugt dabei eine Art
bestichenen Realismus für das
langfristige Ringen um die
Weltherrschaft das Spiel enthält zwar
ein paar pinguin-elemente ist ansonsten
jedoch free to play das heißt du kannst
über den Link in der Beschreibung unter
diesem Video einen vollkommen
kostenlosen Account einrichten und es
dann sowohl auf deinem Rechner als auch
dein Handy spielen und das Beste wenn du
auf den Link in der Beschreibungstext
erhältst du als Bonus 13.000 Gold der in
dem Währung und einem ganzen Monat
Premium Abo gratis dazu dieses Angebot
gibt nur für 30 Tage also nicht zu lange
und fange am besten noch heute damit an
deine Truppen zu mobilisieren neue
Allianzen zum Spielen und siegreiche
Schlachten zu planen wie gesagt euch
kostet es gar nicht und uns hätte damit
weitere informative Videos zu drehen
also nichts los probiert Konflikt auf
nations aus und schneidet euch jetzt an
der Reisen nach Korea
[Musik]
Nordkorea greift mal wieder in seine
alte Trickkiste
Nordkorea vorher hat ballistische Rakete
über Japan ab der 4600 Kilometer weite
Flug des Geschosses könnte das US
Territorium in die Reichweite bringen
19 November 2022 Nordkorea testet
ballistische Interkontinentalrakete mit
einer Reichweite die die gesamte USA
treffen kann Nordkorea vorher am Freitag
eine ballistische Interkontinentalrakete
ab die in der Nähe japanische Gewässer
landete dies war bereits der zweite
große Waffentest in diesem Monat der
zeigte das Nordkorea möglicherweise in
der Lage ist das gesamte US Festland mit
Atomwaffen anzugreifen das altmodische
kommunistische Land mit seiner Ideologie
hat beschlossen zum ersten Mal seitdem
Gipfeltreffen zwischen kim Jong und
Trump und den ehemaligen südkoreanischen
Präsidenten wieder der massive Test
seines ballistischen Raketenprogramms
Affäre mit den besten ist also zu Ende
gegangen aber natürlich ist dies nicht
das erste Mal das pyond sehr provokative
Test durchführen auch 2017 schoss das
nordkoreanische Regime schon zwei
ballistische Raketen ab die über
japanflogen und raketenalarm und
Warnungen
im Luftschutzbunker auslösten und dann
dritten Oktober 2022 Beschluss Pjöngjang
eine Mittelstreckenrakete vom Typ
hassung 12 in den Pazifischen Ozean zu
schießen jenseits der militärischen
Problematik war dieser Stadt vor allem
von politischer Bedeutung und machte
damit deutlich dass die Zeit des Dialogs
vorbei und er nun bereit ist sein Land
zu einer Art militärischen sogenannten
son gundo Prinz zurück zu führen das
heißt das Militär steht an erster Stelle
es handelt sich um einen wichtigen
Wendepunkt über den wir bei
visualpolitik bereits vor einiger Zeit
ein Video veröffentlicht haben
mit der am 19 November getesteten
intercontinentalrakete steckten Jang
seine Ziele sogar noch höher Schätzungen
zur Folge flog die Rakete 1000 Kilometer
weit und erreicht eine maximale Höhe von
6000 km je nach Gewicht eines möglichen
Sprengkopfes hätte dieser Rakete also
ein Reichweite von mehr als 15.000 km
mit anderen Worten sie könnte das
gesamte Festland der Vereinigten Staaten
abdecken es wird vermutet dass noch
Korea hier seine neueste Entwicklung die
haar-song 17 getestet hat die drei bis
fünf acht Buchstaben vertragen kann und
obwohl unklar ist ob Nordkorea
tatsächlich über funktionsfähige
nuklearbe Raketen verfügen einige
Experten davon aus dass die Hasen 17 vor
allem mit dem Ziel entwickelt wurde die
US-Raketen ab der Systeme zu überwinden
die Antwort der USA liest da nicht lange
auf sich warten gleich am nächsten Tag
demonstrierte schon beiden seine
Überschall direkt an der
nordkoreanischen Grenze die beiden
entsendet überall Bombe an die
nordkoreanische Grenze während die
Spannungen zunehmen schickte b1b-bomber
um am Samstag an gemeinsamen Übungen mit
südkoreanisch und japanischen
Streitkräften teilzunehmen nach dem
Pionieren Freitag einen Raketentest
durchgeführt hatte natürlich werden
dadurch vor allem die Bürger Nordkoreas
einmal mehr einen herdenrückschlag bei
ihrem Lebensstandard erleiden aber die
Rückkehr zu von gunduk Trin markiert
auch die Rückkehr der Politik der
direkten und permanenten Konfrontation
mit südkorea Japan und den Vereinigten
Staaten
[Musik]
außerdem hatte der Test dieses Mal etwas
andere ballistische Eigenschaften also
sonst diesmal erfolgt der Stadt
wesentlich horizontaler und in
geringerer Höhe lautet von Nordkorea
bestätigten Garten flog die
nordkoreanische Rakete am 3 Oktober eine
horizontale Strecke von 4600 km
überschritten eine Höhe von 950 km und
erreicht eine Geschwindigkeit von macht
17 also 17-Fache der
Schallgeschwindigkeit und obwohl
ungleich welche Geschwindigkeit sie
unter realen Gefechtsbedingungen unter
dem Gewicht von schaffen könnte würden
diese Testdaten sie in die Nähe eine
Hyper
[Musik]
darüber hinaus hat Nordkorea zum ersten
Mal zweifelsfrei bewiesen das ist in der
Lage wäre die Insel Guam anzugreifen
welche als nicht in kooperierte
Territorium der Vereinigten Staaten von
Amerika zählt
und aufgepasst denn diese Insel ist ein
wichtiger Ort für die militärische
Projektion der US-Armee in der
asiatischen pazifischen Region auf hohem
sind große Mengen militärische
Ausrüstung stationiert und es wird sogar
vermute dass dort Waffen bereitstehen
können und jetzt ist Guam in Fadenkreuz
pionax tja all das hat uns natürlich
veranlasst ein paar Fragen zu stellen
wie fortschrittlich ist das
nordkoreanische raketen-programm
wirklich woher wissen wir überhaupt dass
diese Raketen tatsächlich die USA
erreichen könnten wenn sie bisher nur in
der Nähe Japans niedergehen welche
Fähigkeiten könnte Nordkorea im
Kriegsfall wirklich haben und was
bedeuten diese für das Gleichgewicht der
Kräfte in der ganzen Region all das
werden wir uns heute ansehen also
aufgepasst
hoch fliegende Abschreckung
Nordkorea oder besser gesagt das Regime
von Kim Jong und ist sich bei einer
Sache absolut sicher man will nicht das
nächste Libyen werden in der Tat ist es
nicht ungewöhnlich dass er ausgerechnet
das Gaddafi Regime als Beispiel für die
fatalen Konsequenzen anführt die der
verzichtet auf einer Atomprogramm nach
sich ziehen kann denn Libyen tat ich
2003 und 2011 war er darf sie ein toter
Mann kim Jong und will auf keinen Fall
das gleiche Schicksal erleiden daher
gehört es nun mal zur Wahrheit dass sie
nordkoreanische Strategie völlig
nachvollziehbar ist wenn du als
skrupelloser Diktator wärst denn das
Leben der Menschen egal ist dann sind
Atomwaffen deine beste
Lebensversicherung denn in den Büros der
nordkoreanischen Militär und politischen
hinter verschlossenen Türen ist man sich
vollkommen klar dass die Schlagkraft
ihrer rudimentären Streitkräfte
Lichtjahre von denen Südkoreas entfernt
ist kannst du schweigen von der der
Vereinigten Staaten die technologische
Entwicklung der letzten Jahrzehnte hat
Nordkoreas Armee weitgehend aus dem
Spiel geworfen und genau aus diesem
Grund haben Nordkoreas
verteidigungspläne seit mehr als 20
Jahren nur eine Prämisse berücksichtig
die Kosten einer ausländischen
Militärintervention im Land zu
maximieren mit anderen Worten es geht
nicht darum einen Angriff abwehren zu
können sondern darum dass die Kosten so
hoch sind dass niemand bereit ist diesen
Preis zu zahlen es ist die Politik der
Abschreckung auf ihrem höchsten Niveau
und das ist genau der Punkt an dem
Atomwaffen und ballistische Raketen ins
Spiel kommen und je weiter diese Waffen
fliegen können desto größer ist ihre
abschreckungsfähigkeit und damit die
Lebensversicherung des regis
se wollen dass ihre Atomwaffen die
Vereinigten Staaten direkt angreifen
können sie sind der Meinung dass dies
ihren politischen Einfluss stärken und
sich völlig unantastbar machen würde
deshalb ist nach der Entwicklung von
Atomwaffen der nächste Schritt in der
gesamten Militärstrategie genau die
Entwicklung eines effektiven
ballistischen raketensystems und auf die
Entwicklung von Raketen mit kürzerer
Reichweite und höherer präzisionen die
in der Lage sind US-Basen in Original
war Hawaii und Guam zu treffen
auf diese Weise sollten die Nordkoreaner
dafür das Washington sich einen
möglichen Regimewechsel nicht einmal
ausmalen will vor allem wenn sie mit all
dieser Kraft unberechenbar reizbar und
impulsiv sind es ist eine ähnliche
Strategie wie die eines in die Ecke
gedrängten oder bedrohten Tieres um es
ganz einfach auszudrücken wenn du näher
kommst weiß ich ja so könnte man das
perverse Spielplans zusammenfassen aber
okay das alles ist ganz logisch und
wirklich nichts Neues aber die Frage die
sich viele von euch sicherstellen ist
nordkorea ist ein sehr harmlos und
technologisch sehr rückständiges Land
wie um alles in der Welt ist es möglich
dass es so fortschrittliche Atomwaffen
und Raketen entwickeln konnte
4.600 km weit zu fliegen und macht 17 zu
erreichen ist nicht gerade einen
Kinderspiel nun tatsache ist das
Nordkorea zwar ein bitterarmes Land ist
aber es ist auch ein Land mit einer
singulären alles überschattenden
Obsession
wird geschätzt dass die Regierung jedes
Jahr zwischen 20 und 30 % des BIP für
das Militär aufwendet und aufgepasst es
ist damit das einzige Land auf der
ganzen Welt das in diesem Bereich liegt
mit anderen Worten die nordkoreanische
Wirtschaft dient im Wesentlichen zwei
Zwecken den grundlegenden
Lebensunterhalt und dem Militär
südkoreanischen schätzungen zufolge
belaufen sich die jährlichen
Investitionen in die Streitkräfte auf 7
bis 11 Milliarden Dollar aber natürlich
gibt es auch hier einige Dinge zu
beachten
die Ausgaben für Gehälter und sollte
sind verschwinden gering um euch eine
Vorstellung davon zu geben wie ihr
Sterne generelles erhalten etwas mehr
als 1000 $ pro Monat von ihrer Regierung
okay dieses Hummel lässt natürlich
Einnahme durch Korruption außer acht
aber aus offensichtlichen Gründen sind
verlässliche Zahlen über solche
unmöglich zu bekommen und wenn wir über
die Berufssoldaten sprechen sucht
angenommen dass die Gehälter zwischen 10
und 40 $ pro Monat liegen tja und die
Wehrpflichtigen erreichen nicht einmal
das im Gegensatz zu anderen Armenien
sind die Personalkosten der
nordkoreanische Streitkräfte also
verschwindend dadurch können Sie einen
großen Teil ihrer verfügbaren Ressourcen
für ihre beiden absolut vorrangige Ziele
freisetzen als Verteidigung und
strategische Rüstung und letzteres heißt
Atombomben und ballistische Raketen im
Nordkorea werdet ihr keine moderne
Infanterie Ausrüstung fortschrittliche
Artillerie Hightech Panzer oder eine
moderne Luftwaffe sehen können hat sehr
wohl verstanden all diesen Bereichen
nicht konkurrenzfähig ist
außerdem ist die Entwicklung von
Atomwaffen zu überraschen ist euch auch
erscheinen mag in Wahrheit unglaublich
billig der Grund warum nicht mehr Länder
über diese Waffen verfügen liegt vor
allem in ihrer Verpflichtung zu nicht
Verbreitung und nicht an den Kosten oder
der Technologie
lasst mich das mal kurz erklären nach
Schätzungen der südkoreanischen
Regierung aus dem Jahr 2016 könnte das
nordkoreanischer Atomwaffenprogramm
zwischen 1,1 und 3,2 Milliarden Dollar
gekostet haben und ja diese Zahlen
könnten bis 2022 noch etwas angestiegen
sein aber grob gesagt wird ist nicht
viel mehr als das Sein selbst ein so
armes Land wie Nordkorea kann es sich
also leisten darüber hinausgehen sowohl
südkoreanische als auch US-amerikanische
Geheimdienste davon aus dass sowohl das
ballistische als auch das
nukleareprogramm größtenteils durch
Hacker Angriffe kryptowährungen so wie
illegalen Handel finanziert wurden
[Applaus]
[Musik]
und dies erklärt er natürlich zu einem
großen Teil warum die
wirtschaftssanktion die Entwicklung
dieser Programme nicht stoppen konnten
es ist sogar relativ bekannt was die
Nordkoreaner in verschiedenen Teilen
Afrikas geheime
waffenproduktionsnetzwerke aufgebaut
haben um anrüchige Warlords und
Regierungen zu beliefern
Nordkoreas überraschende lukrative
Beziehungen zu Afrika namibia hat einen
Vertrag mit einem nordkoreanischen
Unternehmen namens Mann Suchti overse
projects abgeschlossen um eine
Munitionsfabrik und eine neue
Militärakademie zu bauen Filme Macher
verbringt 10 Jahre damit Nordkorea
zwielichtige Machenschaften heimlich
aufzuzeichnen mit Hilfe versteckter
Kameras zeigt der Film illegale
Dreiecksgeschäfte bei den russisches Öl
nach Nordkorea geschmuggelt wird
unterirdische Waffenfabriken auf einer
privaten ugandischen Insel und
waffengespräch über nordkoreanische
Waffen die ursprünglich für Syrien
bestimmt waren und das sind nur ein paar
Beispiele für all diese Aktivitäten aber
abgesehen von den wirtschaftlichen
Fragen lasst uns zu dem kommen was euch
wahrscheinlich am meisten interessiert
wie genau sieht eigentlich das
nordkoreanische Programm für
ballistische Raketen aus ist und zu was
befähigt ist das Regime wirklich lasst
uns das mal jetzt genau unter die Lupe
nehmen
die nukleare Vollkaskoversicherung
die Fakten sprechen für sich seit
Nordkorea eine spielt 1980er und 90er
Jahren sein Programm zu Entwicklung
ballistische Technologien gestartet hat
hat das erhebliche Fortschritte gemacht
und ist überrascht nicht dass er seine
ersten Raketen auf Basis sowjetischer
Technologie gebaut hat
[Musik]
die überwiegende Mehrheit der
nordkoreanischen Kurzstreckenraketen
sind verbesserte Entwicklungen der in
der
nato-bekannten Raketen so wurde
wahrscheinlich die erste nordkoreanische
Rakete aus der sowjetischen R17 eltros
oder Scat B entwickelt andere Quellen
vermuten das Nordkoreas sowjetische
Modelle aus der Restbeständen der Russen
gekauft hat so stammen sowohl die
flüssigkeitsstofftriebwerke als auch das
längssystem von Kurzstrecken Raketen aus
russischer Technologie das ist z.B bei
den Raketen Hasso 56 und 7 der Fall von
denen einige sogar in Länder wie den
Iran exportiert wurden
das Problem ist dass die
scatraketentechnologie ihre Grenzen hat
wenn die Nordkoreaner also
leistungsfähiger Raketen mit größerer
Reichweite wollen dann brauchen Sie
effizientere und robustere betriebwerke
die auch in extremen Höhen und bei
eisigen Temperaturen funktioniert
deshalb gründete das kommunistische Land
1999 offiziell die sogenannten
strategischen Streitkräfte der
koreanischen volksarmeden seitdem hat
das ballistische Programm eine 180 Grad
Wende vollzogen
[Musik]
seit Ende der 90er Jahre und Anfang
2000er Jahre hat alle Anstrengungen
darauf verwendet eine neue
Raketenfamilie mit einheimischer
Technologie zu entwickeln über
effizientere Triebwerke oder eine
größere Schubkraft verfügt eine neue
Familie die zu einem Katalog mit fünf
Raketentypen geführt hat eine für jede
Gelegenheit U-Boot gestützt Raketen
Kurzstrecken Raketen Mittelstrecken
Raketen Langstrecken Raketen und die
gefürchteten in der kontinental Raketen
theoretisch hat dieses Programm das
kommunistische Land auf eine Stufe mit
dem großen militärmächten gestellt wenn
es um ballistische Fähigkeiten und
strategische Waffen geht in der Lage
sind atomköpfe tausende Kilometer weit
zu transportieren
und neben den Raketen ist bekannt dass
es Nordkorea gelungen ist Atomwaffen mit
einer Stärke von 15 bis 20 Kilo Tonnen
zu bauen ähnlich denen die 1945
Hiroshima unter gasagne zerstört haben
in der atomwaffenindustrie ist das so
etwas wie ein Auto aus den 1950er Jahren
aber vergiss nicht das auch ein Auto aus
den 50ern gefahren ist und wir reden
hier immerhin über Atomwaffen solange
diese irgendwie funktionieren können Sie
mehr als genug Schaden anrichten eine
Sache die die Nordkoreaner vermutlich
noch nicht geschafft haben ist die
ausreichende Miniaturisierung dieser
atomköpfe um sie mit den besprochenen
Raketen auch abschießen zu können denn
dies ist natürlich das Hauptziele im
Grunde sind das Atomprogramm und das
Raketenprogramm zwei Seiten ein und
derselben Medaille der nächste Schritt
ist dann genau zu wissen wie dieses
Programm aufgebaut ist
tatsache ist dass diese neue
strategische Truppe je nach Ziel
klassifiziert verteilt und organisiert
ist wenn wir dieses Raketen beiseite
lassen und uns auf die modernsten
Raketen mit einheimischer Technologie
konzentrieren können wir folgen
Diversifizierung vornehmen auf der einen
Seite hat Nordkorea eine neue Rakete die
mit relativer Präzision jeden Punkt ins
Südkorea angreifen könnte die Rede ist
von der KN 23 Rakete
die KN 23 ist eine Feststoffrakete
dieser 2019 bereits mehrfach getestet
wurde sie kann von Zügen Lastwagen und
sogar von U-Booten ausgestattet werden
und zusammen mit den Raketen die ihr
gerade auf dem Bildschirm sieht der
puppen-song 1 und 2 wäre dies der dritte
Raketentyp den Nordkorea von einem
U-Boot aus starten könnte sie hat eine
nachgewiesen Reichweite von 430 km und
es wird angenommen dass sie mit einer
abgesägten Flugbahn das heißt mit einem
flachen Stadt weniger nutzen und
geringerer Höhe viele Raketen
Abwehrsysteme wie das amerikanische Idee
umgehen könnte
überraschend nicht wahr nun das ist nur
der Anfang in Bezug auf die nächsten
beiden reichweitenstufen den Mittel- und
landstreckenraketen hat Nordkorea im
letzten jahrzehn besondere Anstrengungen
unternommen und warum und ganz einfach
weil Pjöngjang mit diesen heute in der
Lage ist Japan und Guan zu erreichen
zwei Orte an denen die USA einige ihrer
modernsten strategischen Waffen
dauerhaft stationiert haben und Ihr
könnt mir glauben wenn ich sage das
können ganz abschreckungskraft weil es
Raketen hat die diese Orte erreichen
könnte aus strategischer Sicht mehr als
bemerkenswert ist
die Rede ist von Raketen wie der musst
du dann und der hassung 12 die eine
geschätzte Reichweite von bis zu 4000
bzw 4.500 km haben zum Vergleich die
Insel Guam ist weniger als 3.500 km
Luftlinie von Nordkorea entfernt in
beiden Fällen sind diese Raketen darauf
vorbereitet nukleare Sprengköpfe zu
tragen und sollte es Nordkorea wirklich
gelingen seine Atomwaffen soweit und
miniaturisieren dass sie auf solche
Raketen transportiert werden können
würde dies bedeuten dass ein
nordkoreanischer Atomschlag gegen
US-Basen eine reale Möglichkeit wäre
[Musik]
aber obwohl dieser Raketen zweite
Angriffsmittel sind die den Vereinigten
Staaten wegen der Ziele die sie
erreichen könnten am meisten Sorgen
bereiten werden wir wenn wir die
westliche Presse lesen schnell
feststellen dass die die uns wirklich
Sorgen machen eine ganz andere Gruppe
sind ich meine natürlich die
Intercontinental Raketen diese Raketen
sind ist die das ganze Thema auf die
nächste Stufe heben können denn es geht
um Raketen mit nuklearer Nutzlast die
sowohl Europa als auch die USA selbst
erreichen können
[Musik]
wir sprechen hier vor allem über zwei
wichtige Raketen die hassung 14 und die
hassung 15 und aufgepasst denn das
südkoreanische Geheimnis fällt erste für
voll funktionsfähig das heißt
einsatzbereit es handelt sich um eine
zweistufige Rakete die eine Reichweite
von bis zu 10.000 400 km verspricht
genug um die Westküste der USA zu
treffen die Hass und 15 hingegen ist
eine Art Weiterentwicklung des
Vorgängermodells was sich noch in der
Entwicklung befindet und bisher nur
einmal getestet wurde es wird aber
vermute dass wenn NAS Zukunft
ballistische Test dieser Raketen sehen
können das kommunistische Regime will
dass diese ebenfalls zweistufige Rakete
mit einer Reichweite von bis zu 13.000
km fast überall auf der Welt zuschlagen
kann
ja aber jetzt fragen sich vielleicht
einige von euch aber warte mal wie
können die Nordkoreaner die Reichweite
dieser Interkontinentalraketen denn
testen wenn ihr Land so klein ist und
das ist eine ziemlich gute Frage
schließlich verfügt Nordkorea nur über
eine exklusive Wirtschaftszone die sich
maximal 1000 km vor der eigenen Küste
erstreckt aber wir reden hier natürlich
über Nordkorea es ist nicht so dass sie
sich allzu sehr um das Kleingedruckte
dessen Scheren was manche Leute
internationales Recht nennen die
Tatsache dass die Raketen in Japans
ausschließlicher Wirtschaftsschule ja
nicht wirklich wichtig hauptsache ihr
Problem ist gelöst
[Musik]
um aber nicht mehr Empörung als nötig zu
provozieren werden die Raketen
normalerweise mit einer extrem steilen
Flugbahn getestet sie starten die
Raketen hoch statt lang und ermitteln
dann mit komplizierten Berechnungen die
tatsächliche Reichweite die Rakete
gehabt hätte wenn Sie auf einer
flacheren ballistischen Flugbahn
gestartet worden wäre das mal einen
Blick auf diese Infografik was er sieht
ist die Flugbahn von Raketen in drei
ballistischen Test in Juli und November
2017 durchgeführt worden wobei letzterer
der Hass und 15 Rakete entsprechend aus
diesem Test wurde klar dass sie
Nordkoreaner ihre
Interkontinentalraketen extrem hohe
Höhen von bis zu 4.500 km schießen ja
sie schießen ihre Raketen tatsächlich
bis in die Exosphäre und nach dem
Wiedereintritt in die dichte Atmosphäre
stürzten sie ins Meer es handelt sich
also um alles andere als einen blöd
nordkorea hat bewiesen dass seine
Raketen in der Lage sind US territoren
zu erreichen und das ist besonders
gesagt haben gelänge diese Raketen mit
atomköpfen zu bestimmen es stellt sich
also die Frage wie kann diese Situation
vermieden werden kann das
nordkoreanische atom-raketenprogramme
zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt überhaupt noch
gestoppt werden nun darüber werden wir
in einem zukünftigen Video hier auf
visualpolitik sprechen also vergesst
bitte das Abo und auch ganz wichtig das
Glöckchen nicht um es nicht zu verpassen
und gleich danach kommen die Fragen an
euch welche Maßnahmen würdet ihr
ergreifen um dieser Gefahr zu begegnen
wie sollte eurer Meinung nach mit dem
nordkoreanischen Problemen umgegangen
werden und noch wichtiger glaubt ihr
dass all diese Offensivkräfte eine echte
Gefahr darstellen wie immer sind doch
Diskussion zu diesem Thema schon mächtig
gespannt ich hoffe dass euch dieses
Video gefallen hat und ihr vielleicht
dabei auch etwas gelernt habt falls ja
gibt uns bitte ein Like das mit unseren
Freunden und vergesst wie gesagt nicht
das abonnieren um keines unserer Videos
mehr zu verpassen vergesst bitte auch
nicht das spannende Online-Spiel unserer
Sponsors Konflikt auf nations kostenlos
auszuprobieren wenn du dich nicht
hinzufügen und über militärische
Strategien spekulieren willst solltest
du es unbedingt über den Link in der
Beschreibung unter diesem Video
anspielen
[Musik]
natürlich freuen wir uns auf jederzeit
über eine Spende von euch mit uns hätte
dieses Projekt weiterzuführen den Link
dazu findet ihr ebenfalls in der
Beschreibung unter dem Video macht's gut
und bis bald
[Musik]